Hey Youtubers it's Charlie so Batman versus
Superman teaser aired during the Gotham midseason
finale let's break it down there like two
options here one this would be a dream sequence
or two this could actually be happening during
the movie there is this toy that they're releasing
called nightmare Batman where he's wearing
this outfit so that definitely lend some evidence
to the dream sequence theory of this clip
setup is is that Superman looks like he is
capture Batman and unmasks him if you remember
your Christopher Reeves Superman history there
was an evil version of Superman that sneered
like that I don't necessarily think that that's
was going on in this movie but he's making
the same phase is when Lex Luthor touches
him in this other trailer so Luthor might
have found a way to affect Superman this could
actually be happening the dream sequence option
is that this could be Bruce Wayne just manifesting
his fears about the man of steel because the
set up for most of this movie is is that he
doesn't know what Superman is going to do
or what his intentions are he's too dangerous
he caused all this damage someone has to stop
him before he goes bad visiting here is I
think there's some dark Knight imagery here
some Frank Miller dark Knight imagery these
police in riot gear with the Superman symbols
if you haven't read Frank Miller start and
I comic in a while there's a group called
the sons of Batman so after Batman defeats
the mutant leader a bunch of the mutants start
following him and he takes him under his wing
just really violent Batman fanatics that could
be kind of what's going on here visually as
Zack Snyder was asked point blank a comic
con is this movie in any way tied to the dark
Knight story Frank Miller's dark side story
and he was like no it is not there some visual
references to that just paying to the fact
that Frank Miller's the genius of the story
of the actual movie is something that he and
Chris Tara just came came up with in a room
by themselves that's why kinda think they
have the sons of Batman thing going on here
because the movies coming out in March expect
to get more and more teasers like this is
really closer and closer and don't forget
Deadpool is actually coming out in February
that's the first big comic book movie that's
coming then bandmember Superman then Captain
America Civil War I really like the other
cool thing to talk about in this is the look
of Batman the calling Ben Affleck's Batman
the Batman the Christian Bale's Batman was
referred to as the dark Knight Ben Affleck
is the Batman's and THE Batman Warner Bros.
has been blowing a whole lot of smoke about
this being like the most definitive version
of the character they've ever seen that's
why the green lit a new trilogy with Ben Affleck
I don't know if that's them just trying to
hype it up because obviously haven't seen
the movie yet but I do think it's going to
be really good even if it's not like the greatest
thing that ever hit cinema let me know in
the comments though here's the big question
is this actually happening in the movie or
is this like a Batman hallucination. The question
is is that this really is happening in the
movie does it has something to do with Lex
Luthor synthesizing kryptonite because he
is definitely making some kryptonite if you
guys have it lying around be sure to go watch
Superman three for bearded evil Superman who
drinks in the middle of the day they drinking
Superman but Tom also said I was going to
do a giveaway so I want to do is give away
gift certificate for a Batman theme bunco
you guys can take anyone you want if you end
up winning it was be from Amazon's oriented
enters be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video just like all the other giveaways
that I do if you guys that are big like flash
arrow fans I will be doing a new round of
that reverse flash ring giveaway whenever
I post my flash crossover video tomorrow there
is a crap ton of awesome DC stuff happening
this week if you guys didn't realize Frank
Miller actually wrote a new volume dark Knight
three they released the first issue last week
is called dark Knight three master race you
find out why it's called master race at the
very end of that first issue will be sure
to check it out just in case you guys haven't
seen it you can click here for the legends
of tomorrow trailer all the flash arrow videos
I've been posting and you can click here for
my last Batman v Superman trailer video it's
been a little while since we've gotten a new
trailer. Thank you so much for watching, everybody
high five and I'll see you guys tonight!